Suicide Squad is finally here bringing
us the worst bunch of heroes to ever hit
the silver screen now it's time to
discuss what the ending of the film
means for the DC's movie franchise that
is if it can survive the rough reviews
and actually still get a sequel spoilers
ahead new squad in the final act our
heroic band of villains spared the world
from destruction and one didn't make it
out alive even after the squad saved the
day
Amanda Waller only took 10 years of
their sentences so it was back to prison
for the crew thankfully the squad has a
history of revolving members so we could
definitely see some new blood in a
sequel the teams included the likes of
killer frost parasite dr. light and even
the penguin with El Diablo dead and
Holly Quinn freed by the Joker there are
some slots to fill and he is hoping for
a gigantic CGI king shark Harley Quinn's
misadventures beyond potentially
appearing in Suicide Squad sequel Harley
Quinn will reportedly be getting her own
movie so expect to see the mullet
wielding psycho return even though the
Joker busted her out of prison at the
end of Suicide Squad we're hoping Harley
can spread her wings without being
tethered to the Clown Prince of Crime
her spin-off could include the return of
katana or maybe her longtime partner in
crime
poison ivy perhaps Wallas End Amanda
Waller is a character who quickly
asserts herself as a force to be
reckoned with as a master manipulator
she does what's necessary to serve her
own agenda including killing innocents
to protect her interests she's
threatened every member of The Suicide
Squad including Rick Flagg in the
animated film assault on Arkham Deadshot
makes sure that Waller knows that he has
the upper hand and there's no love lost
between these two so it's possible that
we could see that story advance in a
Suicide Squad sequel justice if you
stuck around long enough to watch the
mid-credits scene you were treated to a
face-off between Waller and Bruce Wayne
while a wanted protection from the media
and
gave Wayne some dossiers of metahumans
in return the true had a tenth exchange
toward the end of the scene with wala
implying that she knows Bruce Wayne is
Batman if there's one thing Waller is
good at its getting leverage what would
happen if the Justice League had to shut
down Task Force X Deadshot and Holly
forever in the comics Deadshot and Holly
Quinn enjoy a turbulent and short-lived
romance meanwhile the chemistry between
Will Smith and Margot Robbie is hard to
miss and a relationship could
potentially be explored in a sequel
after all Deadshot purposely missed his
shot at Holly giving up the chance to
see his daughter if that doesn't scream
I like you
then nothing does the return of katana
katana was on hand to help Rick Flagg
keep the villains in line but we only
saw her a little bit of a backstory and
soul-stealing sword
she's rumored to return in Harley
Quinn's spin-off film but whether she
comes back as a friend or foe is up in
the air we'd like to think she'd be sent
by Waller to bring Quinn back to prison
but we'd also love to see a katana and
Holly team-up she seems nice thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what you think could
happen in the suicide squads future